camera you got one two dozen camera
rolling camera this one's mine I where's
mine in stools for science news
submitted by you are not the father
you are not the father it's the the
viral video to startup companies want
photos of people's poop to build an AI
for research wait what
huh why would they want their poop like
a stinky idea that was really good you
don't know two of my poops look the same
that's like a fingerprint
it's snowflake yeah you always look at
your poops yeah you know I don't because
I wipe and then I just thought with your
and then ends up covering the poops I
never look at my food you're like a cat
you like to dig it after the first
initial skadoosh I'm looking like what's
it going on no then I also do courtesy
flushes because I don't like it smelling
well you don't like to see what you may
know I just saw the Twitter photo where
a guy's holding his [ __ ] and then it
says I can't believe this came out of my
body
ah was he proud of this I can't see his
face it's it's it's his hand like this
and in the background it doesn't that
big it's it's this big and nobody look
at really that's it that's you I'm like
how is it that little cylinder that's
[ __ ] huge but then sometimes it's
like wow that's it let go smooth and you
look at it and it is that big you know
like wow that's crazy I like when you
don't even have to wipe those are those
white now
why you find out no you could just feel
it no I've never done I feel you know I
just look it's like a connection with
your body somebody don't eat you don't
have to wait because you just know how
clean it was exactly right I don't
I always wipe and I I rarely see did you
use your mouth like an [ __ ]
I wiped in me like oh [ __ ] there's
nothing there that's cool but really
yeah nothing there
what a [ __ ] braggart I know what an
angel I guarantee that [ __ ] still stinks
though her [ __ ] he's going like this
the smartest anyway always lie to your
ladies always that's the best way oh
wait were you lying when you said I look
skinny today no no serious okay cool but
that's a lie so these two startup
companies that one is called
Aggie and the other one's called seeds
health and they want people to submit
photos of their poop in order to develop
this AI to build this AI for research
into gut related diseases and to help
people with health conditions their own
bowel movement so the AI is getting
records of different poops can identify
different [ __ ] oh we got bail I'll bag
DD dude they used his [ __ ] underwear
what did terrorist leaders of Isis
guidance really yeah so the ISIS leader
he had a mole like steal his underwear
from his [ __ ] like dirty hamper oh
yes I don't know if they have a hamper a
nicest place of course they do
yeah you think you got like a wicker
basket or something he's like yeah
that's my under T underwear hey because
all these thought is a loincloth from
him yeah he could have been that's what
he wears and then oh so they used it
they used it to identify his body after
he was blowed
how he's like just DNA that was on pics
perfectly they used his dick sweat all
the SpecOps guys they asked you have DNA
samples of every single leader on the
[ __ ] chart you see in the movie so the
minute they killed bin Laden for they
even get back on the helicopter they
have to ID the guy and they're able to
do that scene right then in there
they have [ __ ] like a [ __ ] array of
like blood tests or but not even all
they get cuz they took 23andme underwear
can also be used to identify victims of
sexual abuse which is why Michael
Jackson told them to throw away the
[ __ ] underwear
oh no that's big news how dare you wear
that glove and talk about Michael like
that I just set up a chain of events
that led me to that [ __ ] point and
that's all I wanted to take the bucket
glove off right now and the Hat he threw
it she's just laughing me dude you don't
deserve it damn it's like throw it away
throw away your underwear find your
underwear and throw it away Steve are
you Marvel art Kelly founded always been
the fence and I think that he's innocent
man going down for crime I did not
commit
the video the videos and he picked
immediately have you guys seen my
microphone everyone's been sending me
Thai Michael Tighe Michael's crazy this
[ __ ] do the mic room Tyler yeah like
pretty close face looks exactly like
Michael Jackson like crazy
oh close or from afar can you sleep next
to kids convincingly he'll I don't know
what I have to do with anything Steve Q
looks better than the impersonator we
saw up close didn't look like he did not
look good we set to close if you're
sitting in the Jeep CJ he was dead-on
Michael Jackson boom oh yeah what did
you write
you have no [ __ ] defense
my name is hi and I'm Michael no that's
this is an Instagram video that just
went up like that everyone's been
sending me that holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
isn't it crazy he found a loophole
Michael found a loophole but he's a
little too buff to be Michael there it
is
no I believe the Michael fix with that
so Michael is alive and you went to
Thailand they start taking steroids Walt
started getting too mean for him so he
faked his death it's the same guy I
think and Thailand is a perfect place if
you die that's not good
get a path to you and I think some
hookers do that in a Muay Thai
kickboxing track Thank You TIFF let's
get back to poop please get back to it
be cool if Bobby submitted kalila zweite
poop I think that's me white white white
one like an albino poop I had a white
one too poisoning yeah what yeah have
you never had white boop-boop how does
it happen no I just didn't have the
poison really bad one time where I
couldn't keep anything down
so finally when I was able to eat it was
just saltine crackers and bananas and I
ate that for like two days and then when
I poop it was a white poop Oh
saltine poop - crazy you take a picture
gonna take what you let me did you tell
the CEO to come over
wait a minute wait a minute why wouldn't
you want to be monster okay wait so the
reason why I didn't let him take a poop
it's the story isn't in there he says he
wanted to post it on [ __ ] Instagram
Wow caption at all what kind of way was
it was a shot I've seen [ __ ] pop up my
feet
and do it yeah it wasn't that you did
you push it one yeah he puts a little
picture of like Monica tracer I woke up
google it so apparently there's this
thing called the Bristol stool chart and
it shows you what types of poops you
have cool oh Lord
oh you have to you have to rate your poo
they're not my poop so I'm not attached
to it too disgusting I never seen the
number six
I'm usually three and four yes look
diarrhea no that's it depends on what
you're eating ragged eggs I've only done
one once and I was like I've never seen
one before
I was like that is a [ __ ] I
can't usually do this when you do ones
you feel it oh yeah for sure
you work for each one oh oh wow I get
what anal beads is about yeah one
struggle for sure I've never had one
ever
oh you possibly like from 7 to 2 yeah I
mean okay yes you're number seven bro
seven to seven looks like liquid gold
coming out here I'm [ __ ] spitting out
of my butthole
yeah Bristol stool scale cool stool that
chart and so anyways so they're saying
here like we dare you to hash tag give a
[ __ ] for science we did you don't dare
me to do that give a [ __ ] for Sun we're
building the world's first and largest
poop image database trans so we can
train an AI to change the future of gut
health and we need your help so they
should have made it a new tik-tok
challenge they should you know [ __ ] in a
bucket [ __ ] in a bucket
I like it it's our purple shampoo on
your [ __ ] kids [ __ ] in some Tupperware
send it in the u.s. mail they can see
underwear Oh Shane your underwears oh
you took it too far
well I was thinking of 23 me no you take
a [ __ ] [ __ ] in the [ __ ] tub of
words yeah sure and you
know where to put it in a Tupperware
don't forget everybody for use in two or
three weeks that's what you're supposed
to do when I heard you you're supposed
to take a [ __ ] in a big Tupperware for a
week and then said oh my god that's
right yeah yep yeah he's probably mad
accurate [ __ ] ups it is yep make sure
you wrap it with saran wrap smell to the
drop shipping yeah you could say no to
the insurance mode
yep if you want to if you want a more
accurate result of your race because you
can't do it with spit you got to do with
[ __ ] yeah when they ask how much they
that is in here about how much is it
worth you say about $7 okay you got a
market what about the way it could be
the way might come back if you don't pay
the enough shipping price on that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]